friction it's good for rock climbing and
opening jars but in the world of app
development it's a force that we seek to
minimize app installation is a major
source of friction even for small apps
the installation screen can lose you
five to ten percent of your users and
the numbers just get worse as the app
size gets larger for example 20 percent
of app installs over a hundred megabytes
are canceled by the user this is where
Android incidents really shines instant
apps are native Android apps that
require no installation but what the
heck does that actually mean let's go
ahead and take a look here I've got a
link from a friend about the Google
trips app I press it and I'm immediately
taken into an instep experience it feels
like a native app because it is one
instant apps can be associated with any
URL that you own so you can associated
snap with a search result a tweet a text
message or a try now button on your Play
Store listing let's go ahead and take a
look at how you'd actually go about
structuring your app to be instant
you're most likely used to having a
single app module like this when you
compile your app it becomes an apk that
you can upload to Google Play as you add
different features and assets to your
app that apk size is going to grow
eventually your single app module is
going to take minutes to download now
you haven't really taken the friction
out of the app experience if your users
will spend the same amount of time
staring at that instant app splash
screen that they would have spent
looking at the installing screen so in
such apps enable you to keep all of the
features that your users love but
download them one at a time to do this
you need to take that one big app module
and split it into smaller modules called
feature modules each feature module
contains the code and resources for a
different distinct thing that your users
could do with your app so for example
let's say that I have a travel app I
might have a different feature module
for the code for renting hotel rooms
booking flights and rating those hotel
rooms now usually these feature modules
won't have completely independent code
resources you probably use the same
themes and utility code in each you also
probably use the support library and all
of the feature modules all of this
shared coded resources is there for
extract it out into another module which
is called the base feature module when
your user opens your app they don't
download the whole app they only
download the code for the base feature
module and the future module that
they're currently using this means that
if your user is booking a hotel room
they're not necessarily going to
download the code for flights or rating
if your user that navigates to another
feature of yours the base feature isn't
read outlet it and because you've
modularized your code you can use the
same code base for your installable app
as your instead app now behind the
scenes when you compile as an
installable app these different feature
modules will act like a collection of
Android libraries but when you're ther
compiled as an instep you're going to
get a zip file which you'd then upload
to Google Play this zip file contains
separate apks for each feature module at
runtime
these apks are loaded and composited
together to provide the adapts
experience Android studio 3.0 has been
designed with tools to help you modular
eyes and create instant apps it includes
a refactoring tool for splitting code
into modules the app links assistant
makes it easy to generate the code
needed to associate the URLs like you
own with your instant app feature
modules
there's also an in steps SDK with MDK
support and ap is for showing install
prompts the cookie API makes it easy to
transfer data from the incident app to
the installable app and configuration
apk support helps you reduce module size
more details on all of this are the docs
linked below the 3.0 Android Gradle
plugin was built with multi module apps
in mind and it compiles multi module
projects fast this table shows speeds
for a project with 130 modules finally
there are two new plugin types
specifically for building instant apps
the feature plugin for your feature
modules and the instant at plugin okay
so as we saw before you have modules for
all of your features and the base
feature module you're also good to
include two additional modules just for
building the app the installable app
module which builds your installable app
and the internet module which builds
your insta the install the app module
uses the Gradle application plugin but
the instant app module uses the new
Gradle in step plugin your feature
modules then use the new feature plugin
the feature plugin is kind of cool
because it will make either an APK
versus a library depending on whether
it's being built by the instant app or
the installable app module now after
using the correct Gradle plug-ins for
each of your build files you just have
to set up the dependencies between the
modules then you're ready to build both
instant and installed apps for some
hands-on experience converting a regular
app to an instant app check out the
Android in synapse code lab now if you
are itching to convert your own app we
also have tons of documentation and
resources about the requirements and
processes for getting started and if you
ever find yourself stuck you could reach
out on Stack Overflow with the Android
in stabs tag that's it for today happy
building
[Music]